[Music]
hey everyone welcome to our installments
of Harry Potter theory in this video
we're going to be discussing the five
most powerful witches and wizards and
came from ravenclaw house I've covered
the other three houses in previous
videos so be sure to check those out as
well
ravenclaw is best introduced in the
sorting hats own words or yet in wise
old Raven CAW
if you've already mined where those of
wit and learning will always find their
kind each of the four houses are known
for their unique and defining
characteristics
hufflepuffs are known for their loyalty
and hard work Gryffindor's for their
bravery and their ends for their cunning
so how about Raven claw what are they
known for the answer of course relates
to knowledge and wisdom while Hufflepuff
and Gryffindor get all of the glory
Raven caws produced some of the most
powerful and talented witches and
wizards ever to grace the Wizarding
World now if you know Hogwarts history
which you should then you will know that
hogwarts had four founders Rowena
Ravenclaw Salazar Slytherin Helga
Hufflepuff and Godric Gryffindor the
four founders enchanted a hat the
sorting hat a hat that would allocate
students to each of the four houses
after the student places the Hat on
their head
it begins to analyze their mind and
places them in a house based on how
closely they resemble one of the four
founders Gryffindor Vali bravery raven
core valued intelligence
hufflepuff valued hard work and
Slytherin valued aspirations for power
with that in mind let's take a look at
the five most powerful witches and
wizards of Ravenclaw
number five Garrick Ollivander coming in
at number five on the list is Garrick
Ollivander now you may know Garrick
Ollivander from Ollivanders one shop in
Diagon Alley one of Harry's first stops
before beginning his first year at
Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry Ollivander was a british
half-blood wizard born in the year 1908
he was the proprietor of Ollivanders one
shop taking over the family business
which was founded in the year 382 BC
Ollivanders father garbled was the owner
of the shop when Dumbledore was given
his first wand when Ollivander began
attending Hogwarts in his youth he was
quickly sorted into Ravenclaw house as
we know one of the defining
characteristics of Ravenclaw is
intelligent
and Ollivander was certainly not lacking
in intelligence this made ravenclaw the
likely choice for a man like him
Ollivanders high level of intelligence
meant that it was not long before he was
considered to be one of the most
talented one makers in the entire
Wizarding World going to Ollivanders
before attending Hogwarts was an
absolute staple Ollivander
revolutionized the way that one making
was approached and before he took over
his father's 1 shop it was common for
Wizards to use a broad variety of wand
cause where previously witches and
wizards would present the wand maker
with an object they wanted to use as
their wand core Ollivander disagreed
with this method as he felt that it
affected the one's temperament instead
Ollivanders sourced powerful magical
substances and enclosed them in wonder
woods from this point onwards when a
witch or wizard came into his shop they
would be paired with the wand that was
best suited to them Ollivander famously
remarks that the wand chooses the wizard
in addition to being one of the most
impressive one to makers Ollivander had
many other special talents and abilities
he could produce nonverbal magic operate
an even new conjuration an advanced
branch of transfiguration conjuration
allows individuals to transfigure an
object out of thin air as his only talk
to talented students at the newt level
Ollivander could also produce a
noncorporeal Patronus charm and showed
great wand versatility able to pick up
the ones of most others and use them
almost instantly without issue number 4
Ignatia wild smith ravenclaw house has
an illustrious history most of the great
Wizarding inventors and innovators were
in our house including Ignatia wild
smith the inventor of flue palette
Ignatia wild smith was born in the year
1227 she was a witch and wizard inventor
and she began attending a Hogwarts
School of Witchcraft and Wizardry in the
year 1938 when she started the school
she was immediately sorted into
ravenclaw house and this proved to be
the appropriate choice given that Wilde
Smith were gone to become a prominent
inventor after graduating from Hogwarts
she further pursued herbology which she
was particularly interested in this led
to invention of flue powder flue powder
was of course a glittery magical powder
that was used by witches and wizards to
travel using the flue network a
Wizarding fireplace network that
connected at most buildings Ignatius
breakthrough with flue powder earned her
a spot on a chocolate frog card in
13:20 the same year that she died we
don't know much more about Ignatia but
we do know that she looked remarkably
similar to maleficent number three the
gray lady
aka Helena ravenclaw Helena Ravenclaw
acade the gray lady was the daughter of
Hogwarts founder Rowena Ravenclaw helena
was among the first generations of
Hogwarts students and began attending
the school while her mother Rowena along
with the other three founders were at
the school attending the school while
the founders were still there was a huge
advantage in Helena was often taught in
the magical arts by her own mother who
is thought to be one of the most
powerful witches of all time this led to
Helena becoming quite powerful by
modern-day Wizarding standards however
Helena was unusual and that she was
envious of her own mother this led to
her eventual theft of Rowena Ravenclaw's
diadem a tiara said to grant wisdom to
the wearer a few years into her magical
education she betrayed her mother by
stealing the diadem believing it could
make her more powerful and running away
from Hogwarts the betrayal embarrassed
Rowena who told no one the diadem was
missing on her deathbed however she did
send a young men to find Helena so she
could see her daughter for one last time
when marina ravenclaw fell ill she sent
to the bloody baron who was then alive
to go and find Helena who had fled to
Albania the baron was in love with
Helena and when Helena rejected his
advances he stabbed her killing her and
then turned the knife on himself when
Helena died she returned as a ghost the
Gray Lady oh yes our house ghost is the
Gray Lady the rest of the school thinks
she never speaks
but she'll talk to Raven cause she's
just particularly useful if you lost or
we've mislaid something Helena held
extremely high standards for herself in
life which was part of the reason that
she was so envious of her mother who is
remarkably clever this thirst for
knowledge and notability however did
result in extremely powerful magical
ability even after death the great lady
could often be seen wandering around the
Hogwarts castle reading Jude even
sometimes attended Transfiguration
classes number 2 filius Flitwick this is
where the power really starts to pick up
filius Flitwick was one of the most
powerful wizards in the entire Wizarding
World
he was the resident charms master at
Hogg
and head of Ravenclaw house flip WIC was
a descendant of goblins which accounts
for his small stature and a former
dueling champion he was among the most
powerful of Hogwarts staff a similar in
power to McGonagall and superseded only
by Dumbledore and Snape a speaking of
eccentrics who like our head of house
professor filius Flitwick people often
underestimate him because he's really
tiny we think he's part elf but we've
never been rude enough to ask and he's
got a squeaky voice but he's the best
and most knowledgeable charms master
alive in the world today his office door
is always open to any ravenclaw with a
problem and if you're in a real state
he'll get hurt these delicious little
cupcakes he keeps in a tin in his desk
drawer and make them do a little dance
view in fact it's worth pretending
you're in a real state just to see them
jive Flitwick was born in the year 1958
and began attending Hogwarts in the year
1969 that brick had always valued
intelligence which meant that his
personality was very much in alignment
with the house that he had been assigned
to during his time at the school
Flitwick achieved high grades in all of
his owls and newts particularly in the
subject of charms something he was
particularly talented at after leaving
the school flipbook went on to become a
master duelist and join champion he
supposedly has a shelf full of trophies
to prove it
flipbook had a high level of knowledge
in defense against the dark arts and
during the Battle of Hogwarts he was
personally responsible for the defeat of
a handful of Death Eaters that was also
personally responsible for putting up
their defenses around Hogwarts which
kept the Death Eaters at bay for an
extended period of time
the defenses around the castle were of
course a result of flix charm work which
was the area of magic that he was most
skilled in Flitwick is thought to be one
of the most haunted charms teachers that
ever taught at Hogwarts and had no
difficulty producing even the most
complex complicated and powerful shield
charms Flitwick could also produce a
Patronus which is the mark of a powerful
wizard in addition to Zhu Ling and
charms flipbook was also first in
Transfiguration and conjuration and was
able to conjure objects out of thin air
number one
Rowena Ravenclaw coming in at number one
on the list is Rowena Ravenclaw one of
the four founders of Hogwarts and the
original Raven hall while we don't
actually have a lot of information on
Rowena what we do know is that the
of Hogwarts all four of them were
immensely powerful the hawk was founders
a widely thought to have possessed power
that was entirely and comparable to most
modern-day witches and wizards Rowena
was born sometime in the tenth century
in Scotland and was a close friend a
fellow founder Helga Hufflepuff who was
from Wales there is much speculation
that both the location and name of
Hogwarts were chosen by harina who
dreamt that a warty Hogg was leading her
to a cliff by the lake she also came up
with the ever-changing floorplan
ravenclaw was thought to be the most
brilliant Witch of her time perhaps even
more powerful than Helga Hufflepuff and
showed considerable talent in a
multitude of magical disciplines
Rowena's skill in charm work contributed
to the creation of the sorting hat a
sentient hat that would sort students
into houses for generations to come
she also created an enchanted her own
diadem which would enhance the wearer's
wisdom this is the same diadem that her
daughter willing to steal Rowena could
also produce a pro Ternes charm and
there was some speculation she was also
first in divination she was a truly
powerful witch that is entirely
deserving of the number one spot on his
list and that's it for this video I
think there's some room for rearranging
some names here but I did my best what
do you guys think who were your top five
let me know down in the comment section
below
until next time you're a wizard Harry
[Music]
you